don't wave at me previously on Star Trek
and always shall be this is a great
scene in Star Trek 2 but Spock did not
do the live long and prosper sign until
actually saying live long and prosper
also the first two minutes of this movie
are literally footage from the previous
movie Jesus made the final frontier
whisper narration more than two minutes
of cloud and space credits that do
nothing for nobody if the movie is
directed by spot then that takes all the
fun out of trying to find Spock the
death of Spock is like an open wound it
was a dark and stormy night
your timing is excellent mr. Scott you
fixed the barn door after the horses
come home well that's a dickheaded thing
to say especially over the old ship
radio you think Scotty doesn't know this
already ass a tweak sir but you don't
have a tweak so I'll do it funny into
well that was easy hey everybody it's
Christopher Lloyd
you know from taxi the Klingons keep our
us as pets proving once and for all that
the Princess Bride and Star Trek take
place in a shared universe this is
basically a space 8-track which only
makes sense if the movie is made in an
era where eight tracks are still a thing
which it was so still sending the
8-track Ness of it all this whole ship
appears to explode but the people here
get to chill like nothing's happened for
a split second before the explosion
reaches them on in HD you can totally
see the slightly lighter background box
behind the enterprise as it passes over
this planet never notice that until I
intentionally nitpick this movie for
YouTube which suggests it's still
probably pretty good effects for its
time still sending it because I have a
sin counter to pad you know space porn
that could double as a sex ed video
hey it's Excelsior Sulu's future ship
from undiscovered country meet my
friends the great experiment um that
experiment works and it saves your ass
three movies from now but scoff all you
want old-timer I
and if my grandmother had a wheel she'd
be a wagon but wouldn't she though ya
better go check that alone you're only
the captain of this ship those two
officers didn't sign up for this
Enterprise is 20 years old Jesus they
let that thing fly around for 20 years
and the crew was complaining about
retiring it I mean I'm on the side of
Starfleet here in your absence Genesis
has become a galactic controversy you
are all under orders not to discuss with
anyone your knowledge of Genesis this is
something we could have told you long
before you got back but it feels better
doing it now after you could have
violated the policy already you running
on that on the Genesis device I get that
the chicken that earlier scene stole and
gave them this my question is when did
Kirk find the time to record himself
speaking authoritative Leon Genesis
since the last movie the only answer is
the flight home to earth but then I
counter with why isn't dr. Marcus making
this video lose this video you've made
for I make a video of information you
are going to personally deliver in hours
when you get back to earth wouldn't I
already have the Carol Marcus explainer
video about it from the ratha Khan I
guess my point is this is one of the
most expositional use only videos to
ever appear in a movie instead of a dead
moon a living breathing planet now
exists with no warmth or energy from a
nearby Sun we also generate 10 double
doors in order to sustain a life on the
planet this is where the fun begins
attic that is not Saavik couldn't you at
least pick the metrics that Eaton kind
of resembles Kirstie Alley sector 2
indicating desert terrain minimal
vegetation but why the Genesis project
creates life out of nothing
how would that include a desert with
minimal vegetation cross-referenced and
verified an unidentifiable life-form
reading do you even hear yourself
speaking that incongruous sentence
verified unidentifiable readings why
don't we beam it up yeah sure you're an
unidentifiable life-form why not luckily
the captain is hilariously and obviously
by-the-book so this idea is not
entertained ahora has a ravioli ring
well few that search for Spock didn't
take long and well spot trusted you and
you denied him his future Spock's dad
the audience everyone in the universe
except for Kirk seems to realize the
Genesis planet would revive Spa mine
melding just got a whole lot sexier oh
yeah Sarek is getting more free homemade
porn right now with green aliens than I
ever will even after seeing bones
literally say things Spock would say
after breaking into Spock's quarters
then hearing about Vulcans mind melding
with someone before they died
Kirk still doesn't make the connection
that Spock's
essence is inside bones yes he wonders
aloud his Spock joined with someone else
and goes to check the video but he
should know its bones instantly no man
it's insane how many angles the
enterprise was recording the throne
right
it's almost cinematic repeat and augment
augment what's the Starfleet Jurgen
version of the zoom and enhance cliche
exercise caution lieutenant when the sky
retires he'll be decorated as the most
careful captain Starfleet ever produced
there are life-forms these were microbes
on the tube surface microbes by their
very definition are microscopic living
organisms I hate to be nitpicking but
these seem way more visible without a
microscope than usual also mmm
unexplained alien space ravioli and the
search for Spock has n touch and
microbes got our hopes up gen Ewell in
life and your career stand for
rationality not for intellectual chaos
so this asshole just described the
opposite of what Jim Kirk's career has
stood for no one will be seated during
the Spock McCoy hybrid goes to the bar
scene this videogame is clearly stupid
there I said it
how soon is now Star Trek character
inspires the most popular song the
Smiths ever produced McCoy is basically
Spock at this point but only the secrets
of the Vulcan nerve pinch didn't
transfer for some reason I guess the
reason is comic relief but still no one
pulls a punch better than William
goddamn Shatner
yes let's put away that amazing super
useful Destructoid gizmo and never use
it again in the future history of our
adventures board of Kirk and Sulu
breaking bones out of prison should be
all over Starfleet at this point and the
enterprise the number one search
location but these simple facts will not
get in the way of the plot also a movie
will make it seem like hijacking and
piloting a Starfleet vessel with a
handful of people is easy even though
star trek into darkness would have us
believe it takes a superhuman brain to
create a super ship that is top-secret
and oh my god what have I become the
ship should need more people to operate
it's all in a descent a chimpanzee and
two trainees good okay first of all
that's racist against chips and
Starfleet trainees second of all why
does any starship go out with a crew of
hundreds if they're this easy to run
with six people third of all is that
velvet this captain is clearly not
captain material this mother files as
nails excelsior powering up waters to
pursue because we the rogue stolen ship
can still see Starfleet ship status and
active orders naturally I had no clue
what Scotty did to override Starfleet's
lockdown on the space doors all we saw
was Scotty and Kirk looking hopefully at
them I'm simply going to assume the
reason they open is bull movement also
if they have that kind of control over
the space doors they should be able to
close it behind them and make sure that
faster better ship doesn't follow them
even if Scotty sabotage the other ship
thank God for the plot of this movie
that these were the only two starships
anywhere in this area as usual hey
doctor souvenirs from one surgeon to
another all that stuff my stole from the
other ships transwarp Drive I have them
right here for you to look at because
that's one best speed to Genesis even
though that prison break was a kind of
unseen it's taken nearly 50 minutes for
the enterprise to finally Star Trek 3
this unclothed child should probably be
a dead Spock sickled Captain Spock okay
I need you to go through his whole range
of emotions here and perfect all the
same I'm going to advise Starfleet and
get instructions I need to pad my most
cautious captain statistics in time for
the whispering rose awards banquet
captain Buford won last year and by God
he will not get a second
the moral of this story is stop being so
goddamn careful all the time you might
get blown up by a surprise Klingon ship
run by docker protomatter an unstable
substance which every ethical scientist
in the galaxy has denounces dangerously
unpredictable yeah but if we're talking
about the creation of life on desolate
planets anyway where is the ethics line
drawn we're gonna have to shame Kirk's
kid for breaking the rules on a project
like this sin
captain Esteban my compliments but make
sure to do it in a careful manner you'll
like that this goes on for some time now
that we've cloaked here's a shot of
Krug's dog for no reason what do I find
weakly human a Vulcan boy and a woman
that's racist three times Federation
starship approaching bring me up
how come a bird of prey Klingon ship
can't fire while cloaked at least until
undiscovered country but it can beam
people in and out while cloaked it's
always bugged me there that distortion
see it and Kirk just made cloaking
technology obsolete or else it was never
very good to begin with or else no one
prior to Kirk bother to use their eyes
instead of the sensors no shield my
guess is right they'll have to decloak
before they can fire yeah but why can't
you raise your shields and fire have I
not seen countless Star Trek's where
they had their shields up and we're
still able to shoot enemy ships I mean
the and despite giving their full power
to the weapons systems two torpedoes
don't destroy the Klingon ship at all
the shield's non-responsive the
automation systems overloaded I didn't
expect to take a center combat you know
oh come on you couldn't bring this up
until now where were your concerns
before this happened and what a bunch of
bulls to create artificial conflict also
the shield is non-responsive but can't
you still fire some torpedoes or is
automation overload code for we can't do
anymore
Kirk survives this uh-huh just huh hey I
don't know why we didn't bring some sort
of blaster with us down here so a knife
will have to do I guess I can't see how
anything could go wrong oh no something
went wrong well at least they got the
one out of the three that isn't integral
to the plot turn on passage you kill my
son
you knew him for like two hours don't
get all dramatic about it come on fast
oh yeah I forgot that's racist
Yes Doctor sequence two code one 1a I
love how these assholes have working
self destruct codes for a decommissioned
ship that King stole from space dock
awaiting final code for one-minute
countdown code zero zero zero so
basically the final self-destruct
password for enterprise is password then
in transporter Bay's really handle this
kind of complex multiple asshole beaming
especially since the ship was just hit
and apparently has very little power
this feels like a new level of bull
eaten for transporter beams I for one am
glad that the enterprise is
self-destruct sequence allows for the
cinematically pleasing throwing of fools
into the air before the whole ship
explodes Enterprise wreckage just tells
me they'll find a way to rebuild this
for the next movie which is about Wales
by the way puberty strength what
happened he gave his life to save us
space Jesus son of Kirk Star Trek 3
really loved mauve or really love
washing White Star Fleet tops in the
same load as Red Star Fleet pants one of
the two and that is some Lion King level
Rock movement right there and krug
didn't even need to sing us off this
planet created by an artificial god-like
substance is playing the deus ex machina
to perfection during this fight see
falling sideways mom
- luckily beam me up is the only Klingon
Kirk knows needs to work on the
Christopher Lloyd impression but he
probably knew malts wouldn't ask
questions about that oh yeah aura - mad
you had to sit this one out for some
reason good job being here on Vulcan at
the end for a celebratory Hut without
any explanations or conversations
beforehand they just dragged Spock into
this funeral ceremony not briefing bones
on what he might have to do for Spock to
keep Spock a lot or any kind of Spock
preparation at all I mean Bob that's
stupid
no one even explained to Kirk how far he
could go into this glorified funeral
parlor I guess no one had any
conversations of any kind before going
through with us I asked for Pfau tarp on
the reef Yujin what you seek has not
been done since ages past and then only
a legend your request is not logical oh
but these three women holding up their
right hands and wearing bunny ears is
logical just do the foul tour pan lady
can someone tell me why I'm aroused
right now is it all the cross dissolves
and intimate close-ups that are fully me
into thinking I'm watching softcore porn
literally over five minutes of
ceremonial vulcan bull we already know
the outcome up so bones is okay Spock is
walking upright does no one on Vulcan
stop to think about the fact that they
just pulled off the foul tour pan which
was just a legend before tonight you
assholes believe in ceremonies and a
bunch of bull so it's hard to believe
you and step back and go god damn that
was remarkable why would you do this
because the needs of the one outweighed
the needs of the many
Kirk flipped the script on you Spock
diam wait a minute that still doesn't
make any sense I can't help but think
this whole thing could have been avoided
if they just brought Spock back to his
home planet in the first place sure he
would have gotten that sweet sweet
Regenesis to magically come back to life
but we could have avoided this movie at
least bring on the whales
we need her to speak where can you get
you next time gadget next time this is
the Nebuchadnezzar on approach
requesting access to gate 3
Nebuchadnezzar this is ion control
maintain present velocity and standby
you
no Jim the enterprise would never stand
the pounding mom phrasing no one would
have believed in the early years of the
21st century that our world was being
watched by intelligences greater than
alcohol as yeah yeah but this time I've
got the money
AJ yeah called I in decoding what's on
our side elevator agents on their way up
the tree to exit
he should check up please have certainly
changed around here
I remember when this is all farmland as
far as the eye could see
oh man Peabody on all of this